ja deine ganz präzise
tötungsaktion mit einer ganz besonderen
waffe die wir uns hier in dieser sendung
einmal genauer anschauen wollen da ist
sie und julian robbie ist hier bei uns
im studio unser militärexperte die uns
der uns diese ninja missal wie es hier
heißt genauer erklären kann denn diese
rakete arbeitet mich mit sprengstoff
sondern mit schwertern die herausfahren
dann abgesetzt von einer drohne eine
ganz besondere technik was genau steckt
da dahinter julia ja ganz genau das ist
also eine präzisionswaffe die man eben
nur einsetzen kann wenn man ganz genau
weiß wo ist das ziel beruf befindet es
sich um man eben ganz präzises angreifen
kann also da heißt es schon gesagt das
ist eine eigentlich eine klassische
hellfire rakete die eben von einer
drohne einer in dem fall eine reaper
drohnen der usa abgefeuert wurde die
aber eben kein sprengstoff an bord hat
sondern bei ihrem einstieg im
messerscharfe klingen in alle richtungen
entfacht und dazu muss eben ganz genau
entstanden das können die usa das können
nur die usa das heißt man hat vielleicht
einen tötungsauftrag sie mal 12 metern
wo wirklich jeder der da ist der wird
auch getötet dazu muss allerdings die
braune auch auf 12 meter genau hier
treffen und das hat diese reaper drohnen
bzw auch denn diese hellfire rakete die
sind ninja rakete dann auch getan das
war einmal drauf schauen juliane auf
diese spezielle waffe also die diesen
präzisions schlag jetzt dort ausgelöst
hat in kabul was sagt das auch über die
kenntnisse der usa jetzt in dem land das
hier quasi fluchtartig verlassen haben
vor ziemlich genau einem jahr offenbar
hat man noch recht gute informationen
dort in der hauptstadt zumindest in
kabul die usa haben das land verlassen
die us drohnen haben das land nicht
verlassen wir haben also sichere
informationen auch immer wieder von
fotos das permanent vier us drohnen vier
us drohnen über kabul schweben etwa
15.000 bis 20.000 metern sie sind also
so hoch dass wenn die taliban luftabwehr
hätten die könnten wir haben mit nicht
angreifen die usa wissen ganz genau auf
den meter genau was passiert dort in dem
land und sie können eben mit der technik
des crm mit der aktuellen technik die
wir auch benutzen könnte man mehr können
sie aus diesen 50 kilometern gesichter
erkennen sie können genau sehen wer ist
wann auf welchen ball kommen und
offenbar wurde wie wir auch gehört haben
von den beiden über sechs monate genau
angeguckt wo ist der mann ist er draußen
man macht er seinen spaziergang und so
weiter man hat dann gesagt jetzt können
wir diese drohne und diese waffe
einsetzen die eben seine familie nicht
gefährdet sondern nur ihn tötet
faszinierender präzision faszinierender
waffe die den al-kaida-chef jetzt
getötet hat julian röcke mit 1
hintergründen zu dieser waffe vielen
herzlichen dank für deinen besuch